في الأصل هبطت في برودواي في عام 1957.
الآن هذا الفيلم لشكسبير روميو
وجوليت يظهر على الشاشة الكبيرة مرة أخرى
بفضل ستيفن سبيلبرغ ، ها هي
نسختهم من
الليلة بدأ كل شيء الليلة
[موسيقى]
وانضم إلينا الآن
كاتب سيناريو الفيلم الحائز على جائزة بوليتزر  - ربح
الكاتب المسرحي توني كوشنر مرحبًا بك مرة أخرى
في البرنامج ، فلا بد أنك مسرور بأن
التقييمات السابقة رائعة
حقًا ،
أعتقد أنه في عام 2014 ، اتصل بك سبيلبرغ
لأول مرة بشأن هذا ما
كنت تعتقد أنه يعني هل كنت تعلم أن
هناك بالفعل فيلمًا مبدعًا  اممم
التي تعرفها شغلت
خيال الجميع لذلك لفترة طويلة ،
نعم أعني أن فيلم عام 1961 هو بلا
شك
أحد أكثر الأفلام المحبوبة أه
في تاريخ السينما وبالتأكيد
أحد أعظم المسرحيات الموسيقية ، إنه
أيضًا مصدر بعض الجدل ولكن  إنه
أه إنه بلا شك جزء رائع
من صناعة الأفلام وستيفن
وأنا أحب الفيلم 61 كثيرًا جدًا ،
لذا عندما سألني لأول مرة أه إذا كنت
كنت مهتمًا بفعل هذا
، اعتقدت أنه مجنون ، وقد استغرق الأمر بعض
الوقت حتى أغير رأيي ، لكنني في
النهاية
قلبت الناس
[الموسيقى]
كنت متحمسًا جدًا حيال ذلك
وقضيت وقتًا رائعًا في العمل عليه
اشتهرت ناتالي وود بأنها
كانت تعرف أن اللون البني لدورها هو
من النوع الذي تستخدم فيه كلمة جدل
حول بعض جوانب الفيلم الأول
الذي تعرفه ،
أخبرني بما فعلته
لإخراجها من هذا النوع من الجدل والدخول فيه
العالم الحقيقي اليوم
وأنت
تعلم هل كنت متأكدًا دائمًا من رغبتك في
القيام بذلك نظرًا للخلافات أه التي
كانت موجودة حوله ،
نعم أعني
أم تعلم ، ذكرت أن
هناك خلافات حول قصة الجانب الغربي
أعني تحديدًا من
هناك
مشاعر بأن التمثيل
في كل من المادة المصدر نفسها في
الفيلم
الموسيقي عام 1957 وفي فيلم روبرت ويس جيروم روبنز
كان هناك
مشكلة  lems وهناك مشاكل بلا شك
أه إنه
منتج من وقته أم الموسيقى الأصلية
وفيلم 61 كان هناك
أشياء لم يتم
القيام بها الآن بما في ذلك وجود ممثلة واسعة
من أصل أوروبي مثل ناتالي
ستلعب دور بورتوريكو  فتاة مراهقة
ذات وجه بني
والعديد من القرارات الأخرى التي تم اتخاذها والتي
كانت
إشكالية تمامًا ويمكنني أن
أفهم أنها تسببت في
ألم شديد للناس وأنا حقًا
آخذ ذلك على محمل الجد الآن وأه
ستيفن وأنا أخذنا الأمر على محمل الجد عندما
هاجمنا أه
العمل المتمثل في صنع نسختنا الخاصة من
قصة الجانب الغربي والتي
تستند إلى حد كبير إلى عام 1957 الموسيقي
من نواح كثيرة أكثر مما
تفعله في أوه
في فيلم 61
يمكن فهم سبب وجود عداء معين
تجاه قصة الجانب الغربي
أم ولكن
أه
الثاني
من الواضح أن ستيفن وأنا لم نشارك
هذا الحيوان ، لذلك لن نصنع
الفيلم في المقام الأول ،
وآمل حقًا أن يأتي الناس لمشاهدة فيلمنا
الثاني ، وأعدكم في التنوب  خمس أو
عشر دقائق إذا كانت لديك شكوك حول
سياسة أه لقصة الجانب الغربي ،
فسترى أشياء لم ترها في أي
نسخة من الجوانب الغربية قبل ذلك جيدًا ،
ولا أريد التخلي عن أي شيء ولكن
هذا سيحدث
ربما إذا كنت متفتح الذهن تجعلك
تفكر بطريقة أخرى